mais mes chers collègues madame la
rapporteur
monsieur
nous poursuivons les travaux donc de
notre commission d'enquête en
auditionnant Monsieur Jean-Marc auvergre
président de la filiale française de la
société américaine
ikhia leader mondial de l'exploitation
des données de santé spécialisées donc
je cite la fourniture d'information de
technologie innovantes et de services
d'études de recherche sous contrat
utilisant la donnée de la science pour
aider les acteurs de la santé à trouver
les meilleurs solutions pour les
patients elle est née de la fusion de
deux sociétés américaines
couine-t-il je suppose qu'on prononçait
comme ça au quintil à la française
spécialisée dans les études cliniques et
IMS heart qui propose des études du
conseil et des services pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique
de feuilles nous avons souhaité vous
entendre aujourd'hui parce que nous
auditions nous ont permis d'identifier
plusieurs points cruciaux qui entrent
dans votre business model d'abord la
connaissance de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement du médicament la
cartographie et la traçabilité des
risques de rupture et le traitement de
l'information disponible en la matière
ensuite le suivi de la disponibilité des
médicaments l'articulation des
différentes plateformes existantes et
enfin la question des lacunes et des
défaillances de cette information et du
pilotage de l'approvisionnement pour ne
pas utiliser parfois la problématique de
transparence or il via en tant que
courtier en données de santé se présente
elle-même comme à l'interface des
industries et établissements de santé
des pharmacies des agences au
gouvernementales des autorités de santé
et des payeurs au cœur du jeu en quelque
sorte les données auxquelles vous avez
accès nous vous donnent un regard
privilégié sur la problématique des
pénuries de médicaments et vos
publications couvrent à peu près toutes
les questions relatives à la
consommation à la dispensation et à la
production de produits de santé et donc
pour le sujet qui nous intéresse les
médicaments vous avez d'ailleurs été
consacrés sur le sujet des pénuries
comme un
interlocuteur incontournable du
gouvernement
vous nous direz exactement à quel titre
avec la nomination de Madame anorelli
épices de Florian directrice associée
accès au marché chez igvia parmi les six
personnalités de la mission born mission
interministérielle chargée de formuler
des pistes avant l'été l'été arrivant à
grands pas nous y sommes bientôt sur la
régulation et donc le financement des
produits de santé quant à vous monsieur
Aubert vous connaissez bien le monde de
la santé du médicament au gré des
allers-retours que vous avez effectués
depuis le début de votre carrière
professionnelle entre la sphère privée
et la sphère publique ce qui vous permet
d'avoir une vision globale de tous
l'écosystème puisqu'il est constitué à
la fois de
considération publique et de l'action du
privé vous êtes successivement passé par
les cabinets des ministres Jean-François
Matigny et Xavier Bertrand par la Caisse
nationale de l'assurance maladie vous
connaissez donc notre assurance
nationale qui joue un rôle important
dans la question du médicament et par le
cabinet de conseil Jalma spécialisé dans
le secteur de la santé puis vous avez
exercé à partir de 2013 des fonctions
dirigeantes au sein de l'une des
sociétés américaines donc via et issus
avant d'être nommé en octobre 2017 à la
direction à la tête de la Direction de
la recherche des études et les
évaluations et des statistiques que nous
nommons l'adresse dans le cadre de ces
fonctions vous avez notamment dirigé la
tasse fort sur la réforme de financement
de la santé était l'un des responsables
du rêve data hub la très décriée
plateforme très décriée en tout cas qui
a amené un certain nombre de
commentaires la plateforme numérique des
données de santé vous avez enfin en
décembre 2019 quitter l'adresse avant
même le lancement de la plateforme pour
revenir chez igvia donc à la présidence
de la filiale française je vais donc
vous céder de la parole pour un bref
propos introductif qui vous donnera
l'occasion de nous présenter depuis la
position particulière qui est la vôtre
et votre rôle important finalement
d'observateur et d'interlocuteurs vous
analyse des préoccupations concernant la
prévention et la gestion des pénuries et
médicaments sujets qui je le précise de
nouveau est exponentielle nous avions
réalisé une mission à l'été 2018 au
Sénat à l'époque donc à laquelle nous
participions la rapporteur et moi-même à
l'époque il y avait à peu près 700
médicaments pénurie nous serons rendus
en 2023 et nous sommes entre 2500 et un
peu plus de 3000 en fonction des
critères et des moments ensuite madame
Laurence Cohen rapporteur de notre
commission d'enquête vous poserez une
première série de questions je précise
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu
publié avant de vous donner la parole je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête et
passive des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite donc monsieur le Président a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure et on
allume votre micro
je vous remercie et je vous passe donc
la parole merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la présidente Madame
la rapporteuse mesdames les sénatrices
mesdames messieurs messieurs excusez-moi
tout d'abord pour préciser la société
donc à cuvia dans ces différentes
fonctions suit effectivement les la
commercialisation des produits de santé
c'est pas ça l'activité c'est une
activité qui est devenue un peu moindre
que d'autres aujourd'hui mais
cela dans à peu plus de 100 pays dans le
monde donc les pays bien sûr d'Europe
que l'intégralité des pays
d'Amérique d'Asie mais aussi un certain
nombre de pays africains nous
nous avons pu s'apercevoir disons que le
sujet des pénuries était jusque au covid
un sujet qui existait mais qui n'était
pas un des sujets clés
dans la discussion et on a vu qu'avec
après l'épidémie covid un certain nombre
de pénuries ce sont accrues et ça nous a
conduit à essayer de réfléchir avec
toutes les données qu'on avait comment
on pourrait apporter aux différents
gouvernements en Europe aux différents
gouvernements dans le monde des
informations qui leur permettraient de
mieux gérer
ces types de problèmes alors juste pour
que vous compreniez nous travaillons
beaucoup pour l'industrie de santé mais
nous travaillons suivant les pays
beaucoup ou pas pour les gouvernements
en France on travaille peu pour le
gouvernement français par rapport à
l'industrie de santé dans un pays comme
l'Angleterre on travaille beaucoup plus
avec le gouvernement anglais c'est lieu
à aux habitudes des différents
gouvernements et à leur manière de
travailler ou pas avec des entreprises
comme la nôtre
eu égard assez difficultés qu'on a
remarqué on a émis un certain nombre
d'analyses pour essayer de comprendre
déjà quels étaient des médicaments les
plus en pénurie j'ai envoyé quelques
quelques slides comme ça vous aurez les
chiffres parce que comme ça ça vous
évitera de que je vous donne trop de
détails mais si vous voulez il y a
finalement
si vous voulez dans les pénuries il y a
des pénuries locales se dire dans un
pays on va dire comme ça ou dans un ou
deux pays et vous avez des pénuries qui
sont plus générales à l'ensemble de
l'Europe
est-ce que comment nous nous travaillons
nous travaillons à partir des données de
vente nous travaillons en France par
exemple à partir de données stock que
nous fournissons maintenant à la NSM
nous travaillons aussi à partir des
données publiques reportés par les
différents agences pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe donc nous
avons analysé les données des des
pénuries reportées par les de l'agence
européenne en charge du sujet ça dépend
un peu des pays et de l'organisation et
ça nous a permis de voir que aujourd'hui
on a quand même eu quelques molécules
qui ont fait l'objet d'information de
pénurie plus importante que d'autres
parmi lesquels l'amoxicilline bien sûr
lui prophène le paracétamol donc les
pénuries qu'on a constaté en France sur
ces molécules ne sont pas des pénuries
que françaises ce sont des pénuries
européennes c'est important parce que
bien évidemment les modes de gestion
d'une pénurie
européenne ne peut pas être la même
chose que une
gestion de pénurie nationale
alors avant le covid c'est pénurie
transfert open existait très peu
on avait analysé il y avait des pénuries
dans les différents pays mais il y avait
peu de pénuries transversales pourquoi
c'est important parce que si vous avez
des pénuries dans un pays et pas dans
d'autres pays il y a des surement des
possibilités de répartir les stocks à un
moment donné en cas de besoin et de
pénurie très forte d'un produit qui est
critique il est clair que si par contre
vous avez une pénurie qui est
transversale ça veut dire à l'ensemble
des pays qui est lié en général à des
dysfonctionnements de la chaîne de
production ou à des surconsommation on
pourra le revoir
voilà et bien vous allez bien sûr pas
pouvoir appliquer les mêmes méthodes
la deuxième chose c'est que sur
l'amoxicilline ou on a eu une pénurie
en hiver dernier on a constaté que en
regardant les données de consommation
notamment les données de consommation
anglaise mais c'est qu'un exemple on
aurait pu regarder aussi la les données
français on avait des consommations
aberrantes à un moment d'amoxicilline
par rapport à ce que il y avait les
années précédentes alors pourquoi c'est
important parce que quand vous avez des
consommations plus importantes qui
peuvent être liées soit à une phase
épidémique et là probablement à des
difficultés entre la grippe le covid et
d'autres
problèmes de santé et bien comme les
industriels prévoient en fonction d'une
consommation attendue si dans un pays
important en Europe par exemple il y a
une surconsommation ça peut entraîner
c'est pas automatique mais ça peut
entraîner des pénuries ou en tout cas il
faut regarder sinon l'ensemble des on a
de la surconsommation ou si en fait il y
a qu'un peu pays et dans ce cas c'est
plus pratique mais pourquoi tout ça est
important c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui il
y a les données qui existent pour
détecter si possible les pénuries en
amont ça nous en sommes relativement
convaincus
un autre point que nous avons regardé
c'est quel type de pénurie quelles sont
les médicaments sur lequel il y a le
plus de pénurie donc nous avons étudié
sur 7200 cas actifs de pénurie en Europe
en 2022 on a on s'est arrêté le 17
février 2023 exactement sur ces 7200 cas
signalés par les autorités de pénurie
71% sont des médicaments génériques
produits par plusieurs compagnies de
générique il y en a un 23% qui sont des
génériques qui ne sont pas qui sont
produits par une seule compagnie de
générique c'est des petits médicaments
en termes de marché donc il y a qu'une
compagnie de générique qui les produits
ça arrive souvent et il y a 4 % qui sont
des médicaments de marque les 12%
restants ont pas été catégorisés c'est
lié à des problèmes si vous voulez qu'en
standardise au niveau européen les noms
des médicaments il y a quelques fois des
problèmes de standardisation ou des
sites sur lesquels les agences ne
donnent pas exactement le nom du
médicament et donc on a trouvé un
certain nombre de médicaments je dirais
autre en fait ils rentrent dans toutes
ces cases mais ils ont pas pu être
catégorisé par nos équipes
ça arrive hélas beaucoup quand on fait
de la comparaison internationale voilà
donc ce que nous nous préconisons si
vous voulez aujourd'hui
c'est la transparence pourquoi parce que
plus nous avons une vision les autorités
européennes peuvent avoir une vision
anticiper des punirides d'abord on s'a
permet d'identifier les risques de
pénurie commune
ça permet de se poser les questions
quand on a un accès à une source unique
avec un risque de pénurie là vous avez
un très gros problème parce que ça veut
dire que vous avez un problème sur la
provisionnement de votre source unique
donc
si vous voulez votre risque est encore
plus important si vous avez des pénuries
non communes
les gouvernements européens pourraient
prévoir des mécanismes d'entraide
on pourra en reparler ça permet aussi si
vous voulez de suivre en suivant la
consommation de se rendre compte que
effectivement en cas de consommation
aberrante liée à un problème
épidémiologique on a un risque très fort
d'épidémie pour l'anecdote en fait nous
avons
l'aspect c'est le covid est une épidémie
nouvelle mais avec santé publique France
nous avons pu remarquer que en fait
avant même que l'alerte soit donné sur
le covid le nombre de consommation de
paracétamol avait augmenté il a augmenté
fin février le confinement a commencé le
15 mars et finvrier on était à des
consommations de paracétamol par exemple
qui était synonyme jusqu'à présent
d'énormes épidémie grippe bien
évidemment quand vous avez affaire à
quelque chose de nouveau c'est difficile
de de l'expliquer d'entrée mais ça veut
dire que là aussi on voit que avec les
Lyonnais qui dorment et déjà sont
collectés dans le monde soit par notre
société soit d'ailleurs par nos
concurrents ou Préalle parfois par les
États aussi et bien il est possible
probablement de prévoir mieux et plus en
annoncé pénurie et de discuter avec les
industriels sur les moyens de les régler
voilà quelques éléments
que que je voulais vous donner en
introduction bien sûr je pourrais aller
plus loin sur certains sujets qui nous
intéresseront au cours de cette audition
merci beaucoup je vais passer tout de
suite la parole à Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de la commission
merci
Monsieur pour votre propos liminaire
vous recueillez en fait et analyser
auprès de 14000 pharmacies en France et
auprès des professionnels de santé des
données qui concernent chez bien compris
les volumes de médicaments qui sont
commercialisés et la consommation qui en
effet à votre connaissance est-ce que
les données dont vous disposez sont
accessibles et autoris et exploitée par
les autorités publiques vous y avez un
petit peu répondu puisque vous avez dit
que vos données étaient transmises ou
recueillies par alors tout ou en partie
par l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament donc est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être un petit peu
creuser sur cette sur cette piste et
est-ce que vous donnez sont
complémentaires avec le système national
des données de santé
je vais vous poser plusieurs plusieurs
questions parce que le sentiment quand
même que nous avons au niveau de notre
commission d'enquête c'est que il y a un
travail des différents acteurs et
actrices
de la politique du médicament qui est
vraiment en silo par exemple je vois sur
le le
slides que vous nous avez fait parvenir
je vois que par rapport à la
transparence pour gérer les pénuries et
les prévenir vous êtes en train de
travailler une plateforme de
transparence sur les pénuries mais en
fait il y a plusieurs organismes qui
travaillent sur cette plateforme donc
c'est un peu comme les là il y a des la
liste des médicaments critiques chacun
travaille sur sa liste et au bout du
bout je sais pas s'il va y avoir une
convergence donc voilà ça c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
la présidente l'a évoqué madame anorelli
épi de Florian donc qui est directrice
associée à accès au marché d'Ikea
participent à la mission born sur les
pénuries de médicaments est-ce que vous
avez un avis sur cette démarche et
finalement est-ce que vous avez des
premières pistes de réforme qui ont été
envisagées
ma troisième
question c'est vous joins un rôle de
conseil par rapport aux entreprises pour
leur stratégie de commercialisation des
médicaments sur sur le marché et
notamment en ce qui concerne si on
regarde le site via le site indique que
vous proposez des solutions en matière
de lancement de des produits de fixation
des prix et d'entrer sur les marchés
alors je serai intéressé sur la fixation
du prix parce que en France c'est le
CEPS qui fixe les prix donc qu'est-ce
que vous apportez comme conseil
finalement aux industriels et sur quoi
il s'appuie en fait après pour négocier
le prix avec le CEPS
et ma dernière question ça concerne
donc le fait que l'industrie
pharmaceutique depuis une trentaine
d'années à
procéder à une politique de
délocalisation extrêmement forte alors
c'est vrai
pas seulement en France c'est vrai aussi
en Europe d'une manière globale mais ça
a été très fort en France et notamment
pour des questions de de rentabilité et
donc d'aller chercher dans des pays
moins exigeants en termes de critères
sociaux et de critères environnementaux
la possibilité donc de s'installer
aujourd'hui il y a une révision de cette
de cette politique en se disant que
finalement il faudrait relocaliser étant
entendu que la localisation ne doit pas
se poser pays par pays mais qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une harmonisation une
coordination au niveau de l'Europe mais
est-ce que vous diriez que
igvia a pu avoir dans le cadre de son
activité de conseil
est-ce que vous diriez que vous avez une
influence sur cette politique de
délocalisation et donc de réduction des
coûts à toute à toute force en quelque
sorte ou est-ce que vous n'avez pas été
amené à prodiguer ce genre de conseils
aux entreprises je vous remercie
d'avance pour vos réponses ok alors la
première chose à qui sont
envoyés ces données si vous voulez ça
dépend bien sûr de type de données
pour être très clair aujourd'hui sur les
pénuries nous utilisons trois
plusieurs types de données d'abord les
données de vente donc les données de
vente en France il y a deux concurrents
il y a nous et la société Gers data qui
est qui exploite notamment les données
du giegr et il se trouve que comme nous
sommes en concurrence il y a des par
exemple les faits utilisent les données
de jeu du Gers alors que nous
d'autres voilà c'est le PS n'utilise pas
nos données mais j'arrête à dire c'est à
la fin les données de vente donc
les données de vente sont utilisées par
plusieurs acteurs en France que ce soit
des données d'accuvia ou de notre
concurrent
voilà la deuxième donc le CPS et
l'ensemble de des membres et des agences
qui s'occupent du médicament ensuite il
y a des données de stock donc c'est des
données qui nous sont transmises par les
pharmaciens par certains pharmaciens et
ça les données ces données de stock nous
les transmettons à la NSM aujourd'hui
pour que elle regarde sur un certain
nombre de produits les risques de
pénurie voilà ensuite vous avez des
données international de vente
internationale qui sont l'agrégation des
données de vente de chaque pays qui sont
standardisés parce que on a des circuits
de distribution qui peuvent varier d'un
pays à l'autre c'est sûr que si on
regarde l'Allemagne et la France on va
se dire que le circuit de distribution
c'est à peu près sensiblement le même
mais si vous regardez 27 États européens
déjà pour un produit donné les circuits
de distribution peuvent être très
différents
et donc ça bien sûr et donc on harmonise
ces données internationales et on crée
voilà et il y a effectivement ces
données internationales sont mises à
disposition dans le cadre d'un contrat
au sepait et ensuite vous avez des
données des pénuries déclarées par les
agences qui sont un travail que nous
faisons de manière en langage finalement
récapituler le travail de chacune des
agences et en essayant d'harmoniser le
problème d'harmonisation si vous voulez
c'est que et là si vous êtes voyagé dans
certains pays vous vous pouvez vous
rendre compte
les conditionnements les noms des
produits parfois différents et donc on a
besoin de faire du rapprochement pour
comprendre si par exemple vous avez un
problème de pénurie sur la boxicilline
ou seulement sur des formes pour
pédiatrique enfin et autres voilà donc
c'est ça un peu ce qu'on fait sur les
données de vente le C snds
a exactement les mêmes données
la différence si vous voulez c'est un
problème de processus de la CNDS pour
intégrer pour qu'une donnée devant un
tigre SNF l'assurance m'a dit va faire
un certain nombre de contrôles parce que
derrière il va y avoir un remboursement
financier alors que nous c'est que des
indicateurs de marché donc la donnée de
l'assurance maladie va arriver dans le
SNS à peu près 4 à 5 jours pas dans le
sndf d'ailleurs c'est dans le smiram
interne à l'assurance m'a dit 4 à 5
jours après la vente alors que nous
c'est des données qu'on traite en temps
réel c'est à dire que aujourd'hui agit
plus sain on a à peu près
95% des ventes qui sont faits la veille
et agit plus 3 on a
99,5% des ventes qui sont fait la veille
dans notre panel nous on a panel le snds
c'est complet c'est l'ensemble des
pharmacies voilà mais avec un panel de
14000 pharmacies on a une bonne vision
de ce qui se passe
donc et c'est normal si vous voulez que
l'assurance maladie soit est-ce délai et
c'est pour ça que par exemple pendant la
crise du covid ou certaines données
étaient nécessaires le jour même on
avait fourni à l'État et à l'Assurance
Maladie gracieusement des données qui
leur permet d'avoir par exemple au
moment du lancement des autotests est-ce
que est-ce que ça demandait ou pas
est-ce que les gens les utiliser ou pas
parce que on avait des données un peu
plus récentes comme je vous dis 4-5
jours de différence il y a beaucoup de
gens en fait si vous voulez
oui bien sûr il y a beaucoup de gens et
en même temps
un nombre limité d'acteurs qui
travaillent aujourd'hui sur ces données
si vous voulez pourquoi la société
accueillir par exemple travaille
beaucoup actuellement sur les pénuries
c'est parce que dans beaucoup de pays
européens ça a été un sujet qui a été
signalé comme important et donc si vous
voulez nous on apporte une vision
transnationale
parce que les pénuries si vous voulez la
différence entre une pénurie qui est
purement nationale et une pénurie qui
est transnationale et européenne c'est
que la solution va pas être la même si
vous voulez je dirais à court terme et
même à long terme si vous voulez parce
que si c'est des pénuries qui sont liées
à des problèmes de stockage en France
c'est pas pareil que si c'est un
problème de production générale qu'on
constate en Europe et probablement les
solutions court terme et long terme sont
différents donc moi je ne sais pas si en
France il y a trop ou pas assez
d'acteurs qui travaillent sur le sujet
vous me permettrez de considérer que
l'utilisation de la donnée française la
donnée en France pour le système de
français nous paraît d'un point de vue
international assez faible par rapport à
ce qui se fait dans d'autres pays pas
que sur les pénuries de médicaments sur
la qualité des soins et autres voilà ça
c'est c'est mon constat est-ce qu'il y a
il y a trop de monde ou pas je ne sais
pas
en tout cas je je peux vous le dire
nous notre constat c'est que bien
évidemment
que nous essayions d'apporter à l'Europe
et nous nous discutons de notre
plateforme avec
l'agence européenne et l'agence de
plusieurs pays je vais pas vous faire la
liste totale mais parce que d'abord elle
serait fausse puisque je ne suis pas au
quotidien tout ce qui se passe dans
chaque pays en Europe mais on discute
avec l'Espagne l'Allemagne la Suède et
quelques autres agences la Belgique
voilà et on essaye voilà on apporte ce
que ce que l'on peut apporter
et c'est pour ça qu'on essaye d'apporter
cette vision en peine il faut savoir que
sur la vision européenne qu'on peut
apporter on n'a pas les mêmes données
d'un pays à l'autre c'est pour ça que
que vienne ceci est une société
internationale mais à présent ce très
locale parce que par exemple les données
de stock qu'on a en France dans va pas
dans certains d'autres pays dans
certains pays on a d'autres données
c'est toujours un peu compliqué le
rapprochement vous me demandez si
pourquoi
ce que fait notre collaboratrice
à noëli dans la mission de régulation en
fait elle a été choisie à titre
personnel du fait de son expérience
passée elle a travaillé au ministère de
la Santé à la travailler au snittem et
elle est considérée comme un expert de
la régulation des dispositifs médicaux
mais à ce titre
la mission de régulation a voulu inclure
on nous a demandé si on était d'accord
et comme c'est à titre de ces
compétences personnelles et pas ces
titres d'acuvia dans ces conditions
nous ne suivons pas ce que fait la
mission je suis moi-même je vais être
traditionné moi-même par cette mission
mais en tant que expert de la régulation
du médicament et expert de la régulation
du système de santé plus que en que
membre de la Société accuvia sur
si vous voulez ce que nous faisons pour
sur la stratégie de commercialisation la
fixation des prix les conseils que nous
apportons
aux différents industries de santé que
nous nous faisons avec eux c'est nous
travaillons à réfléchir quelles doivent
être leur stratégie de négociation et
quels sont aussi ce qui peuvent attendre
du prix en France parce que le système
français comme d'ailleurs le système
anglais ou le système allemand sont des
systèmes extrêmement prévisibles
il faut avoir un peu d'expérience
regardez là aussi collecter
quotidiennement les fixations de prix
pour comprendre que tel médicament dans
telle pathologie apportant-t-elle
service médical rendu qu'on peut estimer
à partir des études cliniques et du
résultat des cliniques comme en plus on
est le leader de la production d'être
cliniques on s'est assez bien travaillé
sur des études cliniques
c'est bien on a la capacité de prévoir
et d'anticiper la négociation du prix
après libre au laboratoire de nous
écouter pas nous écouter si vous voulez
quelquefois on leur dit vous obtiendrez
jamais ce prix votre prix objectif
devrait être ça quelquefois il
l'entendent quelquefois il n'en demande
pas c'est leur problème danse à dire
nous nous sommes que en fonction de
conseil nous essayons effectivement de
les aider et de les aider à prévoir ce
qu'ils peuvent espérer ou pas et
comment mener cette négociation parce
que s'il y a un écart initial trop fort
entre le CEPS et le laboratoire ben la
négociation peut durer très longtemps et
il est pas dit en général que ça soit
signe d'un meilleur prix pour le
laboratoire à la fin
sur
la question de la relocalisation nous ne
travaillons pas sur les chaînes de
production donc je peux pas vraiment
vous répondre
ce que on constate bien sûr c'est que
cette nous nous connaissons les chaînes
de production parce que on en a besoin
pour un certain nombre d'analyses mais
nous ne faites faisons pas de conseils
sur comment organiser votre votre chaîne
de production il y a des
cabinets qui se intéressent plus à
l'industrie qui sont spécialisés sur ces
sujets nous nous le sommes pas voilà
[Musique]
sachant que que bien évidemment par
contre effectivement nous suivons où
sont à peu près produites les les
données les les produits de base après
pour quand même apporter un peu
clarification la difficulté c'est que un
médicament rarement enfin ça peut
arriver mais c'est rarement un produit
c'est multiproduits donc après la
question de la relativalisation de la
délocalisation dépend de savoir si
la quantité utilisée d'un produit donné
est forte ou pas si vous avez un
médicament qui qui qui ne fait qu'un une
petite utilisation c'est pas pareil et
et c'est pas le médicament qui va
conduire à la relocaliser c'est pas le
problème c'est pas que la production du
médicament c'est la production de
beaucoup de médicaments voilà après
c'est tout ce qu'on peut voilà on avait
regardé il y a des médicaments sur
lequel il a pu il y a un nombre de
composants très important et la chaîne
de production c'est pas forcément une
seule usine ce que je veux dire c'est
parfois multiplier des chaînes
extrêmement compliquées et pourquoi
c'est important c'est parce que c'est
pas du tout la même problématique de
relocalisation que si vous aviez une
usine qui produisait le produit
j'arrête à ne pas dire c'est ça et le
problème principal c'est
les usines qui produisent les matières
brutes initiales voilà
qui sont des divines chimiques souvent
classées en France en cvso plutôt risque
important ce qui peut avoir conduit
effectivement certaines délocalisations
mais j'aurais tendance à dire on n'est
pas les spécialistes des raisons de la
délocalisation ne travaillent pas sur ce
sujet
merci pour ces pour ces précisions en
fait ce que je voulais dire par là c'est
que à partir du moment où vous aider les
entreprises à travailler sur les prix
la fixation des prix
au niveau des médicaments
vous les conseillez et en fait les
entreprises pour
je dirais pouvoir bénéficier
d'un d'une rentabilité intéressante pour
elle
quand elles ont mené une politique de
délocalisation c'était pour réduire les
coûts et c'était pour réduire les coûts
concernant notamment
les critères
je dirais socio c'est à dire tout ce qui
est salaire etc et aussi vous l'avez
souligné les critères environnementaux
elle est polluer ailleurs que aux portes
de
chez soi puis le dire de manière
familière donc c'est en cela que je me
demandais si vous n'aviez pas un rôle
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
voulez que le produit soit le plus
rentable possible vous pouvez conseiller
vous pouvez être amené un conseiller
la délocalisation c'est ça vous voulez
dire c'est pas c'est pas par rapport à
votre expertise sur les chaînes de
production et donc ça peut avoir et
pourquoi je vous pose la question parce
que ça peut ça a des conséquences on est
en plein quand même dans les pénuries
puisque on a eu au cours de nos de nos
auditions le prix comme étant un critère
pouvant expliquer la pénurie d'un
certain nombre de problèmes voilà je
donne mon l'isolement pour que vous
puissiez le suivre vous comprenez bien
ce qu'on fait nous en général on
travaille sur des médicaments sur les
médicaments sur les premières
inscriptions il y a très peu de demandes
de conseils sur un prix d'ingénierie or
les pénuries c'est essentiellement des
produits génériques ça veut dire que
lequel effectivement on a de le
médicament et depuis parfois de
nombreuses années ça dépend des produits
sur le marché et dans ces conditions là
il y a très peu nous on travaille très
peu sur le prix de ces produits il y a
peu de conseils les formules sont assez
automatiques si vous voulez
[Musique]
lors de la délégation c'est quasiment
n'importe qui peut calculer le futur
prix du générique et puis petit à petit
le prix du générique va baisser
régulièrement chaque année donc si vous
voulez là sur ce sujet nous avons très
peu mais pas que nous aussi nos
concurrents apportent très peu de
conseils parce que sur unique que peut
faire un producteur de générique pour
négocier son prix ça n'existe pas sauf
sur des médicaments extrêmement
particuliers extrêmement rare et qui
sont pas les médicaments dont on parle
aujourd'hui
je vais compléter les questions donc je
voilà on a passé en revue le document
que vous nous avez fourni
et donc les approches pour prévenir les
pénuries vous avez vous avez distingué 4
axes c'est donc c'est votre rôle
à la fois d'analyse de recueil de
données mais de conseils derrière
puisque les axes proposés ce sont des
conseils dans la stratégie pour lutter
contre les pénuries
pour ceux qui les écoutent pour ceux qui
les écoutent en tout cas il y en a qui
vous écoutez puisque c'est marqué les
sanctions peuvent les sanctions peuvent
être contre-productives donc je pense
que le quatrième axe c'est pas forcément
là par hasard on va en parler justement
parce que ça fait partie des sujets qui
sont évolués et qui sont évoqués assez
régulièrement cette question des
des sanctions
vous avez
identifier donc dans dans vos approches
donc la question de
améliorer l'usage de prévisions de
demande et c'est en fait c'est tout le
nœud de la question en matière de
pénurie c'est-à-dire que quand on traite
de pénurie c'est quand il y en a plus et
en réalité le vrai sujet c'est tout ce
qui se passe en amont c'est à dire les
mois de tension contingentement parfois
une tension pendant une semaine et puis
ça revient
et puis toute la part conjoncturelle
c'est-à-dire les périodes épidémiques
bien connues puisqu'il y a des il y a
des
rémanences finalement de annuel de de
moments où on consomme plus
vous est-ce qu'avec les données que vous
avez vous êtes en capacité de de pouvoir
vraiment
exprimer cette prévisibilité des
pénuries quel que soit le médicament
parce que là nous avons des pénuries sur
des anti épileptiques
concernant des anticancéreux
et donc où est-ce que vous exprimez en
d'autres termes est-ce que vous exprimez
ça en terme chiffrés de calendrier de
conduite à tenir ou est-ce que vous êtes
plutôt dans la situation
d'identification d'un certain facteur
d'un certain nombre de facteurs de
risques
qui sont évidemment comme les questions
de monopole de production de de matières
premières ou de ces sujets là
et donc par exemple l'Agence européenne
du médicament qui travaille sur la
question des pénuries de médicaments
est-ce qu'elle travaille avec vous sur
ces questions puisque au bout du compte
à l'échelle européenne il doit bien on
doit bien avoir une sorte de conduite à
tenir alors peut-être pas médicament par
médicament mais au moins sur la liste
des 200 à 300 médicaments dit critiques
ou essentiels qui auront au bout du
compte été identifié est-ce que vous
êtes en capacité de
de proposer la vraie vie quoi vous voyez
ce que je veux dire parce que vous il y
en API vous proposer d'utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle
enfin
vous êtes obligé d'avoir quand même une
part de la réalité et à ma connaissance
inexiste pas comme on dit en tout cas en
France l'identification précise de la
réalité à partir des données
administratives que nous avons à tel
point que on est obligé de par exemple
reposer nos décisions sur les
estimations
de d'excès sur le bruit de fond de
certaines pathologies en France par
logistique voilà donc est-ce que au-delà
de ce que vous exprimez comme étant une
très grande agilité à
utiliser de la donnée de santé d'où
qu'elles viennent vous êtes en capacité
derrière de faire des prescriptions
précises et utiles pour les
pour la puissance publique et pour les
politiques publiques de prévention des
pénuries parce que c'est là où on en est
alors juste peut-être un point nos
recréations sont faites surtout
essentiellement à partir de ce que nous
avons pu voir dans différents pays
européens et des sujets qui nous
paraissent marcher des sujets qui nous
paraissent moins bien marché il y a
voilà donc très clairement
par exemple
au niveau
de certains pays il y a plus de
prévisions de la demande que dans
d'autres pays on a tendance à considérer
que dans ces pays-là il y a des
politiques actives qui sont parfois qui
réduisent la pénurie qui de l'empêche
pas attention ne nous trompons pas si
vous voulez si vous avez un gros
problème de chaîne de production lié à
la fermeture d'une usine quelconque pour
des raisons d'ailleurs
sanitaires vous l'empêchez pas mais vous
voulez régler
monopoles après
attention ça veut dire qu'il faut que
vous ayez des moyens d'action parce que
la prévision elle-même ça vous aide à
mettre des actions si vous n'avez pas de
moyens d'action derrière ben vous allez
pas vous y arrivez pas mais aujourd'hui
oui on a des moyens si vous voulez même
si c'est très imprévisible notamment
l'arrivée d'une épidémie exacte et pas
prévisible a priori on a quand même des
moyens on a des dizaines d'années et en
France on est limités par la CNIL mais
on doit quand même entre 10 et 20 années
de de d'ancienneté sur la consommation
de base on a moins de limite voilà sur
les données de santé elles-mêmes on a
des limites réglementaires mais on n'a
pas donc on a des données ces données
permettent de prévoir si vous voulez ces
données permettent d'analyser si vous
aujourd'hui par exemple la société
recuvia travaille avec sentinelle sur la
prévision des épidémies hivernales et
c'est un partenariat qui date depuis une
dizaine d'années et ce donc on peut
faire beaucoup de choses après
la vraie question c'est
toujours
voilà
comment nous on travaille avec les
agences qui veulent travailler avec nous
on est en discussion avec l'Agence
européenne du médicament comme avec
d'autres agents c'est comme je vous l'ai
dit en introduction tout à l'heure il y
a des pays qui travaillent plus avec
nous et des pays qui travaillent moins
avec nous ça dépend des gouvernements et
de leurs habitudes et voilà donc
aujourd'hui nous nous discutons sur
l'utilisation certaines de nos données
avec la NSM nous discutons pas sur
l'analyse et la prévision de demande et
les risques de pénurie des 6 prochaines
années nous laissons les experts de la
NSM utilisaient nos données c'est voilà
c'est comme ça c'est ça dépend des pays
mais aujourd'hui il y a rien qui nous
empêche de le faire effectivement
et dans d'autres pays on va plus loin ça
dépend complètement des pays
la question de
Pascal Grigny
moi je trouve que c'est pas assez enfin
ce qu'on est moins on est dans une
commission d'enquête donc nous ce qu'on
voudrait savoir c'est en France est-ce
que la gestion de la pénurie elle est
faite correctement
où est-ce que alors c'est jamais parfait
on est bien d'accord mais vous dites il
y a certains pays qui que quoi etc ben
moi je voudrais savoir quel pays fait
mieux que nous est-ce que nous on est
les derniers de la classe ou est-ce
qu'on est au milieu et non mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en place
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait dû mettre en
place pour éviter parce que la pénurie
elle est mondiale certes mais elle est
plus importante ici en France et nous
c'est ce qui nous apporte la commission
d'enquête c'est justement pour savoir là
où il y a là où il y a des problèmes
puis après éventuellement trouver des
solutions et puis trouver des
responsabilités aussi donc ici c'est
voilà mais nous on peut répondre à
certaines questions on peut pas répondre
à tout si vous voulez moi je ne sais pas
qui est si la France travaille nous on
essaye de considérer on considère pas
que la France a un pays dans lequel il y
a un nombre incroyable de pénurie ces
derniers temps on prend considère pas
que les pays dans lequel il y a le moins
de pénurie alors si vous vous demandez
dans un pays qui gère correct qui gère
mieux que l'Europe c'est pénurie si vous
voulez il y a le Danemark par exemple
alors le Danemark on parle si vous
voulez quatre comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure 80 + 80 % des pénuries sont
liés en fait à des médicaments
génériques et donc au Danemark par
exemple il y a tous les deux semaines
des appels d'offres sur le générique
pour
avoir des producteurs à prix donné sur
le générique et ils font ça toutes les
deux semaines voilà c'est le Danemark
est-ce que c'est faisable en France
c'est compliqué parce que c'est un petit
marché le Danemark
mais voilà eux il y arrivent comme ça
au Danemark il y a ils achètent en gros
tous les médicaments à l'hôpital est-ce
que c'est faisable en France c'est plus
compliqué c'est plus gros la France
est-ce que c'est faisable
sur un autre moyen en France c'est c'est
faisable vous voyez
il y a des pays
qui
il y a une autre particularité à la
France la France est le premier pays des
exportateurs parallèles je vais
l'appeler comme ça vous savez que dans
le médicament il y a les mouvements qui
sont faits par les
par les laboratoires il y a des
mouvements qui sont faits une fois que
laboratoire diffuse un produit ce marché
il y a des acteurs qui font de l'apport
et de l'export parallèle
donc là l'Allemagne est le plus gros
importateur parallèle le produit la
France est le plus gros exportateur
parallèle de produits bon on a ni nous
ni c'est pas nous qui lisons c'est je
vous donnerai l'étude la référence
qui sont les exportateurs parallèles
résultats c'est pas nous d'ailleurs
c'est une entreprise haute mais je vous
donnerai l'étude tout la frais parvenir
si vous voulez
je confirme ça nous intéresse si vous
voulez est-ce que ça joue pas nous on ne
sait pas parce que c'est pas nous qui
sont cette étude et on sait pas quels
sont exactement on pense qu'il y a quand
même un certain nombre de produits qui
peuvent être touchés par par les
pénuries qui sont probablement dans
l'apport à l'export voilà alors bien
évidemment en étant exportateur
parallèle bah on peut créer un risque de
pénurie qui n'a pas un pays qui est plus
importateur parallèle ça c'est clair
mais c'est lié aux différents prix il
faut que les gens un intérêt n'a pas
peur après il faut pas se mentir dans le
système européen qui existe et ils
doivent reconditionner les boîtes donc
c'est pas c'est pas quelqu'un qui qui
fait ça sous le manteau c'est pas
quelqu'un qui qui a vu qui allait
chercher 5 médicaments à la pharmacie et
qui va les envoyer en Europe ça existait
plutôt vers d'autres pays quand j'étais
la CNAP on avait trouvé des trafics de
ce type là mais pas vers l'Europe vers
l'Europe c'est très contrôlé si vous
voulez donc c'est pas ça marche pas
totalement comme ça voilà donc si vous
voulez nous ce qu'on essaye de trouver
voilà et tout à l'heure vous me
demandiez pourquoi les sanctions on n'y
croit pas beaucoup on est sur des
produits génériques la plupart a faible
prix donc il y a un pays qui a essayé de
mettre en place des sanctions c'est le
Pays-Bas
et ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il y a
les génériques on abandonné
700 conditionnements ça dépend des
générateurs et autres donc c'est pour ça
qu'en tout ça fait 700 700
conditionnements suite à cela pourquoi
parce que quand vous êtes sur un pays
alors un produit comme le
paracétamol vous avez peu de chance de
l'abandonner parce que c'est quand même
un pays de fortes consommations un
produit de forte consommation mais quand
vous êtes sur un
pays à faible chiffre d'affaires que
vous êtes sur du générique ça veut dire
que vous ne marche ou c'est pas les
marges qu'on a sur un autre produit sur
un produit nouveau c'est pareil j'aurais
dû dire danse à dire dans toute
l'industrie c'est pareil aussi entre un
iPhone et un produit moins moins chic
voilà les marches sont pas pareil si
vous voulez et donc à un moment le
problème c'est si vous risquez de payer
une pénalité est-ce que ça vaut encore
le coup de produire le produit donc si
vous voulez si on est sur des produits
chers ou des produits à fort volume bien
sûr les pénalités ça c'est un choix de
politique publique il y a pas de dire
oui ou non on n'a pas vu le pays comme
ça pour l'instant qui est qui qui ont
qui ont focusé par contre moi ce que
c'est un peu le sens de notre à alerte
c'est quand on est des produits à faible
volume la faible prix
le risque c'est que vous aggraviez de
pénurie en réduisant votre nombre de
producteurs parce qu'ils vont pas
forcément tous abandonner et vous allez
vous retrouver avec plus de produits
avec un seul producteur et ça votre
risque maximum et puis il risque maximum
c'est qu'il y a plus de producteurs du
tout pour certains produits qui sont
tout petits donc si vous voulez c'est
compliqué comme sujet ça veut pas dire
que on époux ou contre les sanctions tu
avais juste dire que ce que on a vu au
Pays-Bas le gouvernement néerlandais
pensait probablement bien faire et se
protéger et bien voilà mais c'est là
encore c'est pas sur tous les produits
qui ont été délicés mais il y a eu un
certain nombre de produits
essentiellement des produits à faible
volume faible prix c'est le cas de
beaucoup je dirais donc c'est pas très
c'est pas très voilà mais faible prix
faible volume
vous payez pas vous prenez pas le risque
et puis la deuxième chose qu'on a vu
c'est que vous vous accroissez le vous
accroissez le bruit parce que les gens
pour éviter les sanctions
à peine signal des rives de pénurie et
l'eau il y a une augmentation très forte
du dérives de pénurie qui ont été
qui ont été signalés par les producteurs
pour éviter les sanctions importantes
mais à la fin quand vous avez trop de
bruit à maman vous savez plus comment
gérer donc voilà c'est nous on dit pas
voilà chaque pays fait ses choix de
m'ont dit pourquoi on a mis dans ce
document que les sanctions étaient
parfois contre-productif je dis pas tout
le temps parfois
produits à faible volume et faible prix
si vous êtes un produit qui est très
rentable pour un laboratoire vous n'êtes
pas tout à fait vous il y a des produits
que j'amène les laboratoires
abandonneront et c'est normal mais voilà
et puis voilà donc c'est un peu
compliqué et puis
les laboratoires qui soient génériqueurs
et autres ne produisent pas forcément
l'ensemble des matières premières du
produit donc si considère qu'ils
prennent un risque avec certains
sous-traitants ils arrêtent de le
produire s'ils ont arrêté parce que le
soleil de sanction au laboratoire final
pas aux sous-traitant initial dans les
causes
identifiées et puis à moins qu'il y ait
des questions complémentaires il y a
quand même la question de la production
et le fait de la mondialisation et des
choix de produits à l'étranger ou même
des monopoles d'ailleurs de fabrication
sur ce travail certaines matières
premières enfin certains principes
actifs
ça ça fait quand même une bonne
vingtaine d'années que que ça évolue
qu'est-ce qui explique alors d'abord
quelle est la part prise par ce sujet là
dans les pénuries de médicaments de
votre point de vue à vous parce que
même si ces multifactoriels doit bien
avoir une influence et ma deuxième
question c'est qu'est-ce qui explique
cette accélération quand même assez
assez importante manifeste et multi
classe thérapeutiques des ces trois
dernières années enfin ces cinq
dernières années on va dire ça comme ça
mais on peut dire ces trois dernières
années on pose covid des pénuries en
Europe nous si vous voulez comme tout à
l'heure on considère que c'est on n'a
pas une explication finale et
merveilleuse simplement ce qu'on
remarque quand même c'est que beaucoup
de la pénurie je dirais transversale à
l'ensemble de l'Europe d'un produit ça
fait même relativement récent et
beaucoup a pas de covid il y avait très
peu de pénurie ça pouvait exister en
préco vide notamment quand vous aviez
des matières premières qui étaient dans
une seule usine et qu'il y avait un
problème y compris il peut y avoir une
fermeture de demande administratives
d'une usine par les autorités de
contrôle des produits parce que on est
sur des produits de santé donc il y a
quand même y compris quand l'usine est
en Chine ou en Inde il y a des
inspections américaines et européennes
qui peuvent conduire à la fermeture donc
ça pouvait quand même arriver attention
je dis pas que ça n'arrivait pas nous la
pression qu'on a c'est que le covid a eu
un impact fort sur les chaînes
logistiques dans beaucoup de domaines et
que le médicament en est un et notamment
pour être très clair c'est c'est plus
les
multinationales
multinationales avec des chaînes
logistiques très intéressantes plus vous
avez des risques or la chaîne les
produits de santé sont quand même des
produits ou la quantité en gramme en
kilo ou en ce que vous voulez et quand
même relativement faible pourquoi parce
que vous avez c'est des produits légers
donc vous avez
concentration de la production d'un
certain nombre de matières premières
dans très peu d'usine vous voulez des
voitures vous pouvez pas avoir deux
usines ou trois visites dans le monde
qui vous produisent toutes les voitures
on ne les a pas encore inventés
même si par contre les puces on a
d'autres problèmes mais je veux dire les
produits chimiques produits pour les
laboratoires c'est des candidats qui
peuvent paraître incroyables en termes
financier mais en termes de poids de
quantité produite c'est petit donc ça ça
a tendance à concentrer la production
sur un nombre limité de du lead
sachant qu'en plus vous êtes des
surrégulines qui sont quand même très
contrôlées ce qui est normal puisqu'on
est déjà des produits humains et donc ça
crée pas forcément l'envie de multiplier
donc d'usine et de donc ça a tendance
effectivement la mondialisation a eu
tendance à concentrer la production et
donc tant que vous avez un problème sur
une chaîne et bien vous avez un problème
qui peut être mondial alors que voilà
alors les autres problèmes ça veut dire
les problèmes non multilatéraux si vous
voulez nous considérons que il y a un
sujet
si on veut y répondre bien je pense que
par contre au niveau européen il y a la
possibilité il y aurait un travail à
faire sur la possibilité de
réutilisation des stocks d'un pays dans
un autre pays en cas de problème majeur
sur un produit quand c'est non
multilatéral ça ça nous paraît plus
simple à traduire il y a juste un sujet
c'était une proposition je crois que le
gouvernement belge fait à l'Europe et
avec lequel enfin tu vois c'est
parallèle les grands esprits se
rencontrent soit il y a eu des
discussions mais il se trouve que j'ai
appris hier que c'était gouvernant belge
le proposais c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on me propose c'est à dire en cas de
pénurie il faudrait accepter que la
notice soit une innotis pour qu'elle
soit en français sinon vous êtes obligé
mais vous l'avez peut-être déjà entendu
vous sinon vous êtes obligé de la de
repas 4G tout le produit alors pour info
si vous avez ça a été réglé depuis
longtemps puisque toutes les notices
dans toutes les langues mais parce que
la notice par rapport à la taille de la
boîte les petites pour un médicament
vous pouvez pas espérer avoir une notice
en 27 langues dans une boîte comme ça ou
alors il faut tripler la taille des
boîtes des médicaments qui poseraient
d'autres problèmes y compris des
problèmes environnementaux mais voilà
c'est une proposition surtout pour des
médicaments qui sont des médicaments
courants ou des médicaments chroniques
ça pose pas un grave problème parce que
je pense pas que la personne lit de la
notice à chaque boîte voilà merci
merci la présidente merci Monsieur alors
j'ai essayé de comprendre un petit peu
je vais revenir sur les trois types de
données que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure si j'ai bien noté données de
vente donner de stocks et donner de
vente internationales
c'est ça les données de stock donc ça
vient des pharmaciens et c'est transmis
à la NSM aujourd'hui oui notamment alors
depuis quand la NSM vous demande c'est
la transmission de ces données
depuis le début de cette année d'accord
et est-ce qu'ils vous ont également
demandé et est-ce que vous seriez en
mesure si de le faire si vous le
demandez de transmettre les données de
vente internationale
et si vous le demandez ce que vous
seriez en mesure de
lecteurs français
gouvernementaux donc il y a pas de
difficultés majeures
vous les transmettez à d'autres acteurs
français gouvernementaux
comment par exemple
internationales
non mais c'est pas c'est juste c'est
deux petites questions je
excusez-moi de les poser mais quand les
questions sont précises elles ne se sont
pas
compris excusez-moi alors j'ai peut-être
un moment de d'absence de ma part et je
vous prie de mon excuser après et est-ce
que dans les données puisque vous
recueillez beaucoup de données y compris
des données d'achat des pharmaciens de
marge
et est-ce que je reviens en donner
internationale est-ce que vous faites le
lien entre
les volumes et prix puisque ça vous
l'avez donc des ventes et le système de
santé qui est porté par le pays
dont vous avez les ventes
vous avez des ventes internationales
donc pays par pays vous savez le nombre
d'unités le volume le montant de vente
pour tel médicament d'accord et vous
pouvez le comparer aux autres pays pour
un même médicament d'accord est-ce que
quand vous faites vos analyses etc vous
faites un lien aussi avec la politique
de santé du pays
ou pas la protection sociale
oui enfin depuis le départ
il faut que j'arrête de poser des
questions peut-être mais mais le prix du
médicament revient sans cesse en nos
discussions nous avons un système de
santé en France
ou le prix du médicament est quand même
largement bien pris en charge bien
remboursé
par la Sécurité sociale avec loi de
financement chaque année où on voit que
chaque année on demande au secteur du
médicament de faire un effort et la
question du prix c'est à peu près le cas
dans toute l'Europe d'ailleurs oui
donc Mike simple question c'est est-ce
que quand vous analysez peut-être que
c'est pas un sujet peut-être que ma
question n'a pas de sens
de telle ou tel pays est-ce que vous
mettez ça en regard du système de
protection sociale portée dans ce pays
la part parce que tout ça est
multicritaire quelle est la part de
responsabilité
dans ce contexte de pénurie puisque on
attribue chez nous enfin les
laboratoires ou bien un certain nombre
d'interlocuteurs nous disent le prix du
médicament est bas en France mais nous
le prier bas aussi parce qu'il y a des
arbitrages via le CEPS et parce qu'il y
a le système
de la sécurité sociale qui permet aussi
l'accès à des médicaments innovants et
parce que par le projet de loi de
finances la sécurité sociale et l'ONDAM
la ligne médicament c'est une ligne qui
est normée sur laquelle on peut pas
déraper et comme c'est multifactoriels
donc il y a tout un tas de sujets qu'on
a évoqué depuis le début mais quelle est
la part sur la pénurie jouer par ce
sujet là parce que vous pouvez comparer
d'un pays à l'autre et vous avez des
abaques de consommation par rapport
écoutez le problème c'est que alors un
la consommation des médicaments et d'un
pays à l'autre suivant le type de
médicaments mais sur des médicaments de
type amoxicilline ou de type paracétamol
ça veut dire ce dont il y a eu les
principaux la consommation est très
diverses elle est liée à beaucoup de
choses à beaucoup d'habitudes de
consommation elle est très peu liée au
prix précis produit dans un pays donné
donc voilà donc il y a des pays il des
pays où on consomme de l'aspirine il y a
des pays on consomme du paracétamol il y
a des pays où on préfère
et autres voilà vous avez vraiment une
donc c'est très difficile de répondre à
la question est-ce que la pénurie dépend
du prix d'un pays donné nous ce qu'on
remarque sur les grosses pénuries qui
font qui font les problèmes de l'année
c'est que c'est beaucoup de vous pourrez
reprendre la liste que vous en avez
c'est beaucoup de pénurie multilatérale
c'est ça la le vrai problème donc dans
une pénurie multilatérale si vous voulez
je ne sais pas si le prix d'un pays d'un
pays a un impact ou pas ce que je dis
juste que j'avais dit sur la sanction
c'est que il faut vous mettre à place
des hémisphères ils vont faire pas des
ils vont pas prendre de risque sur un
produit où ils ont pas de marge sinon le
bail faut faillite si vous voulez
excusez moi de le dire aussi brutalement
c'est on est sur des généricains on
n'est pas sur l'image traditionnelle à
Big Pharma et autres on est sur des
génériques
il est libre différemment leur prix que
sur des gros voilà après ils ont moins
de coût de recherche etc donc voilà donc
forcément c'est ce que je dis après
est-ce que le prix aujourd'hui est
considérable à un impact fort ou pas sur
les pénuries comme on est sur des
pénuries trans européennes voilà après
il peut y avoir un impact on n'a pas
de donner sur les pénuries américaines
même s'il y en a aussi alors que les
prix sont plus élevés il peut y avoir
des impacts sur la facilité de diriger
des produits vers l'Europe plutôt que
vers les États-Unis puisque le prix
américain officiellement et plus élevé
après ça dans le plus élevé ça c'est
énormément dépendant des produits et il
faudrait faire une étine fine que nous
n'avons pas fait pour plein de raisons
et la première raison c'est qu'il y a
tellement d'autres facteurs qui
rentrent en compte que on considère
qu'on risque de pas voir grand chose et
de ne pas pouvoir répondre ni oui ni non
à votre question voilà
y compris dans les dans les comparaisons
c'est extrêmement difficile même au
niveau des pays européens parce qu'il y
a les habitudes etc mais par exemple
quand tout à l'heure vous nous donnez
l'exemple du Danemark qui est très
intéressantes etc et vous dites que tous
les 15 jours enfin c'est énorme toutes
les deux semaines appelle doffe et donc
il lance des des productions mais c'est
une population qui fait même pas 6
millions d'habitants si je me trompe pas
alors qu'en France c'est près de 70 donc
70 millions d'habitants donc
on n'est pas sur la même échelle entre
entre 6 millions d'habitants et 70
millions d'habitants on n'est pas du
tout et on n'est pas sur les mêmes
volumes de vente donc
voilà
je redonne justement pour abonder dans
votre sur le fait que c'est extrêmement
compliqué de comparer parce qu'on est
sur là sur des échelles de grandeur
différentes et donc des volumes parce
que quand même le marché français il y a
tout ça à prendre en compte dans le prix
il y a aussi le fait que et Pascal
grenier l'a dit il y a aussi une
question très importante du volume
[Musique]
je dirais pour comprendre la spécificité
peut-être de la France par rapport aux
autres pays qui je ne sais pas sur le
risque de pénurie mais sur la régulation
du prix la grande différence entre la
France et les autres pays c'est que dans
les 20 dernières années le marché
français est passé de la première place
des marchés européens à la deuxième très
proche de l'Italie et de l'Angleterre ça
veut dire
ouais on ne ça dépend des chiffres que
vous décidez nous de les chiffres qu'on
publie c'est la deuxième je pourrais
vous envoyer notre étude de marché mais
on est proche en fait on est sur des
donc après la question nous on prend les
chiffres parce que il y a les chiffres
en prix de vente il y a les chiffres en
prix remboursés nous on prend les prix
chiffres en prix de vente
le ventes on prend les prix de vente des
producteurs
oui parce que si vous voulez les prix de
consommation
les prix des consommations c'est
compliqué si vous voulez voilà alors à
attention on attaque pas non plus on
intègre pas les remises éventuelles
parce que les remises ne sont pas
transparentes dans tous les pays donc si
vous voulez
les remises sont c'est très compliqué au
niveau international on essaye et je
pourrais vous transmettre un rapport
public nous avons que nous pouvons vous
transmettre sans aucun problème sur
l'évolution des marchés la grande
différence c'est ça c'est que le marché
français était un marché extrêmement
rentable dans les années 2000 pour des
politiques diverses et variées
auxquelles d'ailleurs j'ai contribué
donc je connais bien le sujet il a perdu
beaucoup de son exceptionnalité par
rapport à des marchés européens ce qui
peut expliquer parfois d'ailleurs la
désintéresse éventuellement plus fort
dans l'industrie pharmaceutique
française que dans d'autres
[Musique]
effectivement c'est pas ça je dis pas
mais après nous sur le prix exact des
produits et leurs liens avec leur
pénurie c'est difficile par contre il
est clair que un médicament qui rapporte
peu d'argent à une entreprise il y a moi
il y a plus de il y a plus de risques de
pénurie qu'un médicament qui rapporte
beaucoup d'argent à l'entreprise elle
n'a pas intérêt à la panure alors que
sur un médicament compliqué voilà c'est
combien en fait
la question
et puis sur un médicament courant c'est
plus compliqué de faire beaucoup de
stock parce que couvrir dedans doliprane
c'est difficile sur certains
anticancéreux vous pouvez que couvrir
vous pouvez avoir un stock qui coûte 2
ans c'est pas c'est pas très compliqué
en fait ça dépend de ce que ceux qui
sont en pénurie sont quand même des
anticancéreux très utilisés
même s'il y a il peut y avoir des
pénuries sur des médicaments rares mais
qui a deux fois lié à un problème sur le
sur un des sites de production mondiale
de qualité pendant 15 jours on ferme le
site ça a un impact
merci beaucoup mais je sais pas si je
veux éclairer disons qu'on pose des
questions précises parce que nos
interlocuteurs nous ont donné des leurs
points de vue
la lumière personnelle pas au sens
personne physique mais sur sur les
l'origine des pénuries et par exemple
quand on a interrogé la CNAM le
directeur il nous anime nous à la
question du prix du médicament ça compte
pas par contre les laboratoire et
d'autres interlocuteurs considèrent que
le prix du médicament compte donc à un
moment ça doit être multifactorielle
chacun voit quand même la responsabilité
chez l'autre et histoire de la paillette
de la poutre donc voilà donc on essaie
dans ce magma de de d'identifier la part
joué par chacun des facteurs en fait le
problème c'est que c'est pas forcément
si simple parce que vous pouvez arriver
à des choses très significatifs
qui m'a été posée plusieurs fois de
savoir est-ce que maintenant que les
chaînes logistiques se remettent on va
revenir ou pas
avant comme avant jeudi je ne sais pas y
répondre parce que par ailleurs combien
de temps il faut pour l'ensemble du
système pour refaire tous les stocks je
ne sais pas parce que
on a pas les chiffres de production de
chaque union de matières premières etc
qui permettent d'avoir si on va refaire
les stocks en 15 jours ou si on va aller
refaire les stocks en me disant ce qui
est possible on le voit bien sûr
d'autres sujets merci beaucoup